alex is with us in san diego hi alex
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey there how are you guys doing today
thanks for having me sure man what's up
so i want to thank you guys because i've
been listening for the past six months
or so and i've had a pretty good savings
built up
but uh have baby steps one and three and
kind of backtrack after listening and
building up the courage
and uh this week we paid off twenty five
thousand dollars with the debt and that
was it so
attaboy alex way to go man good job so
you're debt free and do you have your
emergency fund now
we have an emergency fund we have about
130 000
in savings and about 30 thousand dollars
invested
good so still getting used to
transferring it out of uh
out of a bank account it kind of makes
me feel good to open up the app and see
that
those figures to be honest i'm just that
kind of person but i'm you know building
up the courage that way as well
good um i guess my question is they're
just
you know in my heart i don't want to buy
a home right now we're not really settle
down where we're at
we have family in different places but
financially you know we're saving a good
chunk of money every month and our
family tells us buy a house buy a house
um and i know it's not a bad investment
in a lot of ways but
uh from a lifestyle perspective i don't
see it so
i know you know baby step kind of six is
to
is to pay off your home early but i
don't even have a house and i feel like
you know where do i go from here from a
financial perspective your
your family doesn't get a vote alex
yeah i i interrupted you dude
that man won't say anything you you are
you have entered into the territory of
the weird you've entered into the
ecosystem of people who make different
types of life decisions and choices and
so
part of that is comes with people
speaking
all kinds of their various wackadoo
truths to you and usually they're
speaking to you out of love they care
about you
but uh if you're not ready to buy a
house not ready to buy a house if you
don't think you're gonna settle down in
one of the most expensive real estate
markets
this side of mars then hang on to your
cash
right mars has a real estate market
that's the rumor they're working on it
right
so alex here's the thing short-term
that's fine
it is not a good 15-year
25 or 30-year plan and the reason is
very simple
rents go up continually until you own
and what you own you fix the largest
cost item in your in your line item
budget is your rent
your cost of housing you fix the cost of
housing when you buy
and of course you fix it low when you
actually pay it off the second thing is
and rents aren't gonna go anywhere but
up i mean i'm old i've watched rents go
way up my first apartment was 235
a month and you can't even
get a steak sandwich for that you know
so it's unbelievable
uh so yeah you're going to see that
and it's going to rob your wealth over
time if you don't buy
so that's where the idea of
homeownership comes from
because it works for you on stabilizing
your today
and causing wealth building in your long
term tomorrow out of the 10 000
millionaires that we studied
we found two primary areas that caused
them to become worth a million dollars
or more
primary area number one was they
continually invested in their retirement
plans their roth iras are 401ks and good
growth stock mutual funds primary area
number two was they had a paid for home
now does that mean you have to do this
in the next four months or four years no
it does not
but just say if what you're meaning is a
sure as a short-term lifestyle decision
i'm not sure i'm gonna stay here i kind
of want to play this i'm gonna
i'm enjoying the pile of cash right now
that's cool
because probably not gonna stay in san
diego may end up in wherever that's all
okay no troubles with that
but uh the ten-year from you now
version of you needs to own a house is
that okay
yeah that makes sense would you
recommend me if we still are kind of you
know i'm 25 years old my wife is 21
right now so
you know perspective and life could
change change all of that and of course
if we had a family we would
we would be thinking of buying a house
wherever we're at or picking the
location but
when you when settle down more you're
still in play right now
yeah exactly yeah if we get to that
point though and we're still kind of
a little bit mobile would you recommend
getting something you know just as an
investment at that point five or ten
years
down down the line as a backup as long
as you're going to stay in it two years
or more you're probably going to make
money in most
most areas okay so
yeah you know you're not it doesn't it's
not like you can't sell a house
unless you buy a weird house don't buy a
weird house but i mean
you see what i'm saying buy something
that think about the resale
appeal of the product that you're
looking at when you're buying it
you know and so if you buy houses ugly
when you get ready to sell it it's an
ugly house
so you know don't do that buy something
that's got some appeal right
and uh then you can jump in and out of
it fairly easily
um but um you know and in the meantime
go ahead and pile up your cash fund
you might even pay cash for your first
house you're 25 years old with 130 grand
in the bank in no debt
that's that's that's a good that's a
good way out of the pretty studly out of
the garage right there
pretty studly man you're the kind of guy
that could end up paying cash for a
little starter house somewhere
especially if you jumped out of san
diego san diego starter house is a
different world but
i mean if you jumped uh you know into a
more traditional real estate market than
a california real estate market
you might see the ability that you could
pay cash for a 200 000
house pretty nice pretty nice starter
house and that makes it real easy to get
into a fairly generic
product that has a lot of market when
you get ready to resell it it'll go up
in value and again you've stabilized
your largest expense and it's not going
up the rent's not going up and somebody
doesn't come in and go
you know we're gonna sell the house out
from under you and so you gotta move you
get control
of you know this big section of your
life
which is where you live and there is a
an emotional value to that there's a
financial value to that there's a
relational value to that
and i underestimated that for a long
time i was always looking at it through
this roi roi or why what's the money was
the money
and i had a great friend todd who told
me
man your wife needs a home you need a
home your kid needs a home and so
i'd love to hear you mention both of
that dave it's it's something about
roots and security
as well as a way a place to park and
grow your wealth
and that's that's a matter of a life
philosophy though
that doesn't say you have to run out
today and do it absolutely but you just
go
at some point there is value to this
it's intrinsic
as well as financial that's right